ganz modern ctv bis zu diesem moment war
alles okay philipp es aufwärts bis auf
doch dann okay also gamespot recht zur
gamescom ich alles gesehen
platz eins ist klar von 156 instant auf
nun zu einer neuen folge der hacker
schon wie jeden sonntag zeige ich euch
heute wieder die besten fünf hektar der
letzten woche hier wollte gar nicht viel
zu erzählen nur die info wie immer wenn
ihr auch auftauchen wollt dann lasst das
material auf youtube hochlädt am rechten
rand aus nicht gelistet und schickt mir
den link zu dem video mit der erlaubnis
des renten zu dürfen daran habt ihr gute
chancen in der nächsten woche auch
mitarbeiter seien all und blei die
anstalten wir direkt mal mit platz fünf
platz 5 stammt von joghurts oder shorts
und heißt zwei hacker gleichzeitig speed
und kilometer in jump liegt als jude
sein okay das sieht schon mal nicht
allzu ligety war keine killerspiele
feldberg okay da manchmal einen hacker
und spitex safe albers fall noch zwei
andere leute die sie und den hacken
schauen wir nicht angreifen das sieht
verdächtig aus also diese umgesetzt
games mit dem unter anderem der hitze so
dürfen nur diese drei und ein anderer
heißt jetzt gerade drei gegen eins mal
davon abgesehen dass einer aus dem team
heckt mindestens einer alice russell
einer von dem wieder aus so das ist der
dem wir gerade schon beim hacken
beobachtet haben
rennt jetzt rum und angesehen
könnt ihr nicht zu denen der rote der
bedingt gut ok alter sie dir das vor
allem wenn der gerade auf hinter den run
fliegt und belastet seine killer aus für
weil die den aufnehmenden noch wahrnimmt
als entity leute erstmal auf die jetzt
also hitzler felsen sowie den kopf weg
hektar safe auch und also haben sie
mindestens zwei hacker ist die frage ist
was ihr team umgesetzt hätte vielleicht
auch den weg geklappt so auch immer
schön wir miteinander macht super viel
sind auf jeden fall schreibt einfach
echt einer noch kempen bringt nichts
der aber am hacken was erwartet uns die
leute machen hätte mich sehr gern
fakt ist dass diese drei jungs einfach
total hängengeblieben sind sie können im
jahr einfach sich gegenseitig aus dem
trecker entfernen dann finden sie auch
den der kennt sowas würde er jetzt hier
da unten raus zu kommen hat sich der
damals am rand der map pack m
ja ok schönwetter kinder das macht genau
ist so viel sinn
alles klar also die jungs sind nicht
mehr zu retten meine lieblingsszene aus
dem video aus dem meer braut springt auf
stück okay wir springen zur nummer vier
das tier stammt von marek p und heißt
hacker show hacker kampf das heißt wir
haben wahrscheinlich auch hier wieder
mehr als ein hacker in der runde wir
schon mal
ok bauteile oder janko wert ist du bist
der nächste
einmal kurz unterhalb von einer
millisekunde und den hinter sich das ist
das als optiert sie einfach die ganze
zeit so durch die gegend fliegen und so
spielen
wieso geht sowas müsste ich meine kamera
was ist das denn die spielen bewusst auf
einmal löst sich ihre base raus und
versteht alles
ich kann natürlich jetzt gerade mal
nicht warum bringt dann fährt was zur
hölle ist das für ein models und warum
wer wann wie weswegen 13 platz 3 stammt
von powell ibahn und da ist minecraft
hacker auf zeit.de
ja tatsächlich auf den chat
was soll das fragt der himmel delta es
gibt da draußen einfach unerträglich
minecraft später auch in dieser runde
gegen mainz spielen einfach versuchen
widgets zu gewinnen kommt dieser typ und
hängt sich an die fucking laterne an der
decke auch gerade eben bei dem rennen
einfach so beim countdown los und sobald
das rennen eigentlich beginnt ist ja
schon im ziel hat es geschafft mario
party hacker das ist noch mal ein
eigenes kaliber das ist noch eine sache
für sich so ganz großes kino
er fliegt davon los so jetzt achte mal
drauf das rennen startet jetzt gleich
ist schon längstens achtet auf den chat
wenn das rennen startet drei zwei eins
und er es ins sind fertig mit dem rennen
platz zwei platz zwei stand tatsächlich
von einem einsender mit dem namen hekla
prib und passenderweise heißt das video
er stirbt trotz hacks und wir spielen
hier gerade häufig sehr häufig gehen
schau mal rein ok es steht schon
gestorben
hallo wo wir sind
ach du scheiße
als ob er gerade gestorben ist machte
hier drauf mega-show haben fliege ich
die gegend mit dem ersten speed man
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
denn peter pan macht sie die hosen und
jetzt sagt herunter und stirbt einfach
es kam fast bisschen spät für falsch
hand bedienen aber was ist eine
wunderschöne metapher für alle die über
den mit dem hacken anzufangen
es funktioniert so 23 sekunden langen
456 mann ist lustig der luft unterwegs
und dann blieben auf die fresse
vor allem alte auf sg 7
es ist so könnten wir da rumfliegen kann
jetzt irgendwo mal gelesen das auf essen
sieben bühnen anti fly plugin
ausgeschaltet ist weil die druckplatte
funktionieren müssen also die die blues
platten alter gibt richtig kranke sachen
erwäge sie wieder ungefähr ist
vollkommen gestört ungestört okay im
hintergrund lassen wir noch einmal um
düsen und springen mit seinem tod hierzu
platz eins plus eins stammt von sari
oslo und nennt das video heftiger hacker
aufrief wie das jetzt wie aussehen würde
wenn man das wort wörtlich nehmen würde
ein heftiger hacker auf revidiert
einzige forschungsstelle mal einen
typischen visiten hacker aus bei euch
wie stellt ihr euch ein hacker vor
stell dir mal vor dann setzt den auf
revier auf und denke ich irgendwas aus
für die beiden was sie dort machen
dann habt ihr heftigen hecke aufgeben
aber nicht einfach scheiße weil es kein
halb drei uhr nachts ist nein da man den
kurzen und intensiven test an alle
gewartet
alles klar für die ausweitung von platz
eins aber von teddy perlet 6 geholt
auch fälle genannt er würden so
tatkräftig unterstützen dabei zu
untersuchen was hier auf platz eins
passiert ist und er hat unglaublich
schnell verdacht dass es auf den
zeitpunkt ev geschehen ist der typ ist
genial und wir starten das bewegtbild
ganz modern noch über tv bis zu diesem
moment war alles okay teddy pass auf
erzbischof
doch dann okay also wie gamespot
erreicht so etwas passiert im
games-bereich das 1 platz eins ist klar
von 156 instant auf null runter und
gewinnt die runde was ist das denn
momentan ja wo leute drauf zack von 90
50 auf null runter und wie der name ist
schon legal komisch ja pendant league
jetzt 156 auf null und jetzt seine cleo
einfach als wird sagen illuminati
confirmed auf jeden fall die köpfe habt
ihr eine ahnung was für ein hack das
sein kann von 156 auf null runter geht
instant und ihr seht ihr auch rechts ins
spiel counter er läuft der regulär
weiter da wo du nichts geschnitten ich
gehe davon aus so ist da keine item geht
oder so das wirken der idee her passt
das war shoppen in die kommentare
ansonsten danke ich euch fürs zu stellen
und diese woche das kein leichter hat
sich gefangen hat bis zum nächsten mal
und